so klingt das weltall genau richtig
gehört
ihr werdet gleich ist richtig hören wenn
solche aufnahmen werden im laufe dieses
videos zu hören bekommen heute bei pixum
science fiction zum ersten mal so klingt
das weltall
die nasa hat tonaufzeichnungen von der
raumsonde voyager 1 veröffentlicht die
sonde zeichnete sogenannte plasma
vibrationen auf experten bearbeiteten
diese so dass wir sie jetzt hören können
also aus dem vibrationen wurde ein
audiosignal bietet bilder videos und
noch mehr bilder nochmal videos das
kennen wir alles bereits wenn es um
neuigkeiten aus der weltraumforschung
die tonaufnahmen aus dem weltall gehören
allerdings nicht zum üblichen informativ
aber eben genau um ein solches thema
dreht sich dieses video
die deutsche eins raumsonde wurde vor
einer gefühlten ewigkeit ins all
geschossen verachten 30 jahren im
september 1977 verließ die sonde die
erdatmosphäre mit ihr starteten auch
große hoffnung ins all im august 2012
nahm die sonne dann auch noch abschied
von unserem sonnensystem und flog noch
viel weiter drei jahre später also erst
kürzlich konnte die nasa dass erstmals
auch bestätigen
eigentliches ziel der wollte einst war
das gleiche wie das der voyager 2 die
planeten saturn und jupiter genauer zu
analysieren
nachdem dieses ziel erfüllt war
erweiterte sich die zielvorgabe witcher
2 machte sich dann auf den weg zum
uranus und neptun und wollte 1 flog noch
ein ganzes stück weiter
bevor wir zu den tonaufzeichnungen aus
dem all com gibt es noch etwas anderes
zu hören und zwar eine kleine story die
die sonde mit sich bringt und zwar im
wahrsten sinne des wortes neben den
hoffnungen nahmen die voyager 1 nämlich
auch noch eine goldene schallplatte mit
darauf sind menschliche botschaften
gespeichert warum startet man eine sonde
mit kleinen botschaften ausgerichtet
wurden die nachrichten an mögliche
lebewesen da draußen ist sind also
kleine geschichten die gerichtet sind an
aliens und die hören sich so an
ganz anders als die botschaften klingt
der ton aus dem weltall hat sich schon
jemand von euch mal vorgestellt wie sich
das da draußen anhören könnte man kann
es natürlich nicht direkt hören weil im
vakuum wird kanton ausgebreitet aber
diese vibrationen kann man halt zu einem
audiosignal umform ausnahmen aus
mehreren milliarden kilometern
entfernung das sind sie
das waren die geräusche vom plasma
vibrationen welche zwischen dem oktober
november 2012 und april mai 2013 von der
sonde voyager 1 aufgenommen worden
klingt schon etwas ungewöhnlich
ungewöhnlich klingen auch gamer oder
technikbegeisterte würden jetzt sagen
die specs also die hardware der sonde im
innern der deutsche 1 arbeitet ein 22
watt sender zum gleich so eine
herkömmliche glühbirne also mit
glühfaden noch die hatte so 40 bis 60
watt meistens 22 watt ist also nicht
besonders viel und auch nicht besonders
viel oder besonders groß ist der
arbeitsspeicher der sonne
der hat nämlich nur 70 kilobyte ich weiß
nicht ob einer das noch kennt heute muss
man ja speicher er in gigabyte und
vielleicht kann sich der ein oder andere
an megabyte erinnern aber kilobyte gab
es auch mal schon verrückt dass eine
solche sonde derartig ausgestattet ist
aber besser mehr gab es damals nicht
besser ausgestattet werden auf jeden
fall die computer der zukunft mehr dazu
im video computer werden 1000 mal
schneller das papier zur app und zum
block kommt hier unten
allerdings natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung und welche botschaft würdet
ihr ins all schicken
wenn er könnte oder würdet ihr es lieber
nicht machen stephen hawking waren ja
vor aliens vor dem kontakt mit aliens
also schreibt es uns in die kommentare
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran